and in an effort to make the team better
they use the fifth overall pick on
receiver jamar chase reuniting him with
joe burrow here's taylor talking about
the rookie wideout
jamar has been impressive he picks it up
really quickly
uh you know i know there's probably some
new terms that are crossover from some
old terms he's had that
like any young receiver takes takes a
couple days to get adjusted to but um
man he gets lined up quick he knows what
to do he's got great hands
you know he's he's everything we'd hoped
he could be here through through just
the first couple practices but really
excited to see when we can actually
strap on the pads and training camp and
see what his game looks like then
and even more to see what happens when
it's go time week one i think it's the
vikings coming to town right out of the
gates if i recall it it is it's a zimmer
board or is it or is it or is it the
raiders did we have fun with that one no
i think it was i felt like it was the
zimmer bowl to start the the year out it
is
yeah i i know it's not the raiders but
we were we were messing with pete one
day with something along that the lines
of the bengals schedule or something
like that i can't remember pete now
remembers pete is lamenting it over and
over again into my ifb he remembers even
though i don't i've ruined pete's
morning it was inevitable
um and anyway uh hey look jamar chase
and joe burrow we know what they did at
lsu two years ago
yeah if if joe borrow has time to throw
this could get very interesting when you
consider the other weapons that they
have in cincinnati and this is a team
that quietly could become a factor no i
agreed i mean they could be dangerous
especially on that offensive side of the
ball you would sit there and think just
looking at their roster and go um they
have the potential to be a real pain in
the butt and put some points on the
board and some yards on the board and
all that case is a baller i don't think
there's going to be any adjustment for
this guy in the nfl i really don't he
was in a very similar offense in lsu
with that west coast offense that's what
zach taylor runs there you know so
that's why he can get lined up quick he
was in a pro offense so it's not going
to be a huge adjustment for him there
and he's was the best receiver in
college football two years ago and again
he's young he's only gotten faster and
stronger since then so i just can't
imagine him not blowing us out out of
the water i really i really expect that
from the player i think he's that
special and you know you said it you
know when you talk about higgins and
boyd and joe mixon coming out of the
backfield that's pretty damn impressive
group they got to protect the offensive
line and then what joe burrows said the
other day they got to be more explosive
they gotta they can't it can't be 45
throws and big ben roethlisberger four
yard throws at a time
they got to take some pressure off of
joe mixon to make a defense back up so
he can run the ball and it's just going
to help their team overall it's the only
weakness of joe burrows game his game is
almost perfect but i think you've heard
me say before throwing the ball down the
field and some of the power throws
are
maybe if you could pick a little
negative of him it would be that and he
got better at the as the year went on
last year but then of course he got hurt
and we didn't get to see it through but
uh i think that's what he was talking
about a little bit yesterday or the day
before when he made that comment
you know what's amazing about the
bengals right now
there has been no mention no
conversation no concern whatsoever what
are they gonna do with that aj green i
know you're right nothing and and and i
thought of that because
there were a lot of targets thrown his
way last year by joe burrow they could
knock quarterbacks but for whatever
reason the connection wasn't there and
now chase steps into that role that
green had
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports